whoa whoa whoa I didn't know this was
here what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is that that's cool oh my god I
did not know this was here holy [ __ ] I'm
gonna die but this is awesome oh my god
put this in Matt I put this in but it's
all going dark okay anyway okay so that
was new I had no idea that was there
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica that was
the abandoned sea bass I did not know
that was there I honestly didn't I have
no idea how to get back there without
warping but I will get to that in just a
second the first thing that I have to do
is get a seamoth there we go yes okay
the only reason I'm cheating here is
because I'm an experiment uh-oh whoa hey
whoa hello okay then that is bizarre
I am dying cuz this one can't take the
pressure but I just need to be able to
see wait item tink okay I just need to
be able to see where to get in this
thing it looks like oh man this looks
bad
oh there we go right there okay so
that's the entrance for me so before
this blows up I'm going right in because
we don't have a lot of time and I gotta
see what's going on in here
I've never been here before what did
that do DD a photo album log and too
long in the midnight sea that doesn't
help me really it didn't do anything it
didn't say anything apparently that PDA
was just bust but hopefully in the
future that's gonna have something and
that's one of the new machines this is
experimental mode so there's a lot of
things that aren't exactly in the main
game just yet that was another PDA so
not everything is implemented here but
it's super cool that this is all here
just loggia this
this is in the middle of the goddamn
ocean why did they build it in the
purple mushroom caverns this is like in
the caverns beneath everything and
obviously I haven't seen any of this
before and that's because it wasn't here
before this is all new
all these PD is I can't even touch that
PDA because I'm passing out okay there
we go
thank you I guess okay so what I'm gonna
do is I need to get to the island which
is the staging ground of where I'm gonna
do this next thing I'm going to show you
guys the sea Emperor the sea dragon
which is a different version of the
Emperor and some other creatures if I
can get them to work but to do that I
need a place I can go and spawn them
without immediately being killed by them
cuz I don't know if they're gonna be
active at all let's test it out first
oh to be back in my little seamoth it
may not be the USS [ __ ] duck but it's
still pretty cool oh sorry I even know
if I can kill you huh can I kill you I
have no idea
now I'll be honest I've never really
tried yeah you know you're a peaceful
giant ain't gonna bother you you do
alright you do you I'll leave you alone
unless those just broke its spine I just
doomed it to be murdered by a reaper
Leviathan down the road it's still
something just terrifically terrifying
and is it just me or is it more obscure
like the Sun shafts and stuff like it
seems like they added a bit more detail
to this but I'm not a hundred percent
sure because I never like whenever I'm
in the ocean I lose a sense of
everything that I've seen the last time
I was in the ocean I literally have no
idea what to expect down below the waves
at least I found this floating oil and
on the floating Isle I shall start
summoning demons the likes of which
you've never seen
Oh Ron this isn't the beach Wow good
thing this seamoth is expendable
sploosh oh no where's my castle [ __ ]
anyway I need the knife whoa hello you
scanner room
what's a scanner rum I don't know what a
scanner room is but it sounds awesome so
there's a lot of new stuff in the
experimental mode and the next few
episodes that I make will actually be in
experimental mode because there's so
much more to see and there's so much
more to be done when they're constantly
releasing updates through the game so
you guys will see that in the future but
for right now I'm just gonna test
something real quick
okay so to test something I'm gonna
stand right here on the edge of the
ocean and I'm going to spawn just to
test it because this is something that
we've already encountered whoa whoa I
didn't expect it to spawn directly on
top of me god you're huge what the [ __ ]
I stopped it I'm trying to look at
something here
jeezum good golly what is it doing
stop stop being a little butt oh my god
you're such crap there we go
are you dead I don't know where the
Reaper I looked away for just a second
and it's gone should I jump in Oh
jumping it would be a bad idea where to
go let it go where the hell did it go oh
there it is whoa oh man it's just living
its own life now okay so I'm going to be
summoning things in a certain order
because I want to see exactly what they
do before I do it and the next thing
that I'm gonna be doing I'm gonna build
up I'm gonna build up to it so I'm gonna
be warping in something called the
warper oddly enough hello okay so this
thing is
oh I think they fought holy [ __ ] okay oh
you're so big yeah let me get some of ya
oh god this is scary look go away please
I'm just waiting for it to grab onto me
this big meaty claws big meaty claws or
if I can Ram it with my C Mon
maybe that'll be a good use of this
seemeth nevermind it's stuck here well
[ __ ]
well something just got eaten or else it
just shat out its last meal okay so let
me try that again
warper okay so the warper is a creature
that actually summons portals that will
teleport you around it's not fully
implemented obviously but it's just an
interesting creature and a good step up
from the Reaper Leviathan but I've made
a problem for myself with that thing by
whoa oh that's what it does that's what
it was it just teleported cool anyway
okay so the next one is the Mesmer
Mesmer and the Mesmer is actually a
small fish that's supposedly when it's
done it'll stare at you and then oh
there it is there it is it's doing it it
pulls you in and then it steals
healthfully alright you pull me in and
steal way more health no my C Mon you
son of a [ __ ] give it back I'm gonna
slice and dice you okay well that's a
lost cause goodbye have fun whoa I think
I just saw a piece of it explode off
into the hills so that was cool wow that
guy's a dick alright so and if I spawn
more than one Mesmer they will have
staring contest with each other how cool
is that like they literally they'll just
they'll have a little staring contest
they'll be like hey hey what are you
doing hey what are you doing hey hey oh
I'm drawn in by their gaze oh these are
coming
he got me well that's a [ __ ] god damn it
they sped that up quick holy [ __ ]
okey-dokey then whoa where will we will
where am I going
ah [ __ ] not where I wanted to be well
this is a problem I seem to have warped
into the wrong location
don't touch me with your squiggly
tentacles there we go okay
that's much better ah I get this PDA now
even though the PDAs don't seem to be
working good food
yes please alright so now that we're up
on this mountain top I'm going to spawn
another Reapers Leviathan and I'm gonna
see what it does on land hello hi
welcome to the party
what are you doing oh there goes it just
goes right through the floor straight
into the water you know what good for it
I just made another one that's gonna be
even more of a problem for me okay but
the next thing that I'm gonna do is
actually the next step up on the way to
the Emperor and the Emperor scares me
all right here we go
here we go spawn sea dragon whoa oh my
god hello hi friend
he's got the doppio oh my god do a
backflip run nice weld whoa [ __ ] this
guy he's not having a good time right
now he is stuck on the beach and he
can't go anywhere oh my god Oh something
tells me this one isn't implemented
properly
hello let me and you oh I'm gonna ride
you apparently let me end your suffering
bruh oh good I pushed you off into the
whoa ow 80% of my life gone like that
alrighty then good for me well that
guy's just so happy and free oh it's
adorable oh they're gonna fight
I hope they fight okay so either way
that's both of them but the Emperor
needs a special place that's the sea
dragon which is about the same size as
the Reaper Leviathan by the looks of it
just a little not a hundred percent with
it mentally but that doesn't matter
because we're not gonna judge him like
that he still hurts like a son of a
[ __ ] so the next one that we're gonna
do needs a special place an isolated
coast not to be bothered by anybody else
because he's a reclusive king of the sea
let's do this I'm actually going to do
this in the ocean whoa whoa whoa
hi holy [ __ ] I should have gosh I'm
getting out of the ocean me he ate me up
he had me good he he done ate he aided
me okay now that we're back on the
island and I have a bit of a perch with
which to watch and not die hopefully
anyway let's get a good look at this son
of a [ __ ] I mean majestic king of the
ocean hello hello oh you're gonna come
up and say oh oh way to dive-bomb into
the ocean there but at least you're
swimming free oh my god now obviously
not a hundred percent working yet the
animations aren't all there the behavior
isn't all there I mean the reaper
Leviathan is able to coil and move and
actually look like it's swimming
properly in the ocean that that looks
more like that looks more like he's
having a seizure in the middle of the
ocean but that's besides the point that
is the sea Emperor and I'm gonna spawn
next to him a spawn sea dragon they have
kind of the same back like their
tentacles are actually kind of similar
and their bioluminescence are actually
kind of similar to so they may be
related
in terms of a species of a hypothetical
game but it's just interesting to see so
and then the last thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna spawn a bunch of Roberta love
AI offends see these things are elegant
and and we'll just do ten of these whoa
whoa whoa
I shot him off into space yeah okay bye
have fun oh that one's well I've just
populated the entire ocean with just
endless amounts of preper leviathans
hello friend how you doing God is so
huge but apparently and I don't know if
this is the final size that these things
are gonna be but the Reaper Leviathan
actually looks bigger than the other
things like the sea Emperor in the sea
dragon I've never seen them before so I
had no idea what the comparison would
actually be but there you have it that
is what I have to show you it's not done
yet obviously and in the next few
episodes we're gonna be exploring a lot
of very early-stage stuff but it's gonna
be exciting than the less why how do you
do that who did that who did that I have
no idea please stay away but it's gonna
be interesting it's gonna be dangerous
and it's gonna be a lot of fun so hope
you enjoy it so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you
good